Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Clustered.
Today, we have something special. We have
ChainGuard versus
ChainGuard.
We have two teams from the same organization.
Hopefully you're all familiar with ChainGuard. They've been
hiring up all the best talent in the
cloud native ecosystem,
but I'm sure we're in for one hell
of a Clustard today.
Now, before we introduce our first team, I
wanna say thank you to our sponsors.
So thank you to Teleport.
They've been supporting Clustered from the very beginning,
and I can't thank them enough.
We use Clustered on we use Teleport on
Clustered every single week. It's a fantastic product.
I recommend that you check it out. And
if you're not convinced, you'll see us using
it on this very episode. So there's a
lot to love there. Check it out at
Rawkode.live/teleport.
I also wanna thank Equinix Metal. They've been
providing the hardware for every single episode of
Clustard two. So thank you to Equinix Metal.
Now I could run Clustard on some small
VMs with a few cores and a wee
tiny bit of RAM, but I don't. I
run it on big chunky boxes with lots
of cores and lots of RAM because it
makes it more fun. So thank you Equinix
Metal for putting up with that. I really
appreciate it.
Alright. Let us get our first team on.
We have
Changard
East. He's a broken down geographically,
and this is team East. So thank you
all for joining me. How are you all?
Good.
Doing alright.
Good? Happy? Nervous? Excited?
All of the above. Awesome. All of the
above.
Alright. Let's start clockwise directions. Can you please
say hello, tell us your name, and anything
else that you wish to share?
Okay. I guess it's me. Like, my name
is Carlos,
and I work for a chain where this
everybody knows. And, also, I work on the
Kubernetes upstream
and the.
Hi, everyone. My name is James Strong. I
am the author of Networking and Kubernetes.
I also am the one of the maintainers
at Ingress NGINX.
So I
fully expect today to be a lot of
networking issues. Thanks, Thomas.
And I'm a lead solutions architect here at
Shingard.
Hi.
I'm Adrian.
I started at Shingard a week ago. I
hacked it on the show once before as
part of container solutions.
I was saying earlier, I intend to employ
exactly the same tactics,
which were to allow only as a teammate
to do all the work.
Was gonna say, forgot what it was. Oh,
I was at my first in person meet
up for, you know, two years last night.
So I am a little bit slower today.
That's my I'm getting excuses in fast.
Yeah. As many excuses are like that that
don't worry about it.
Alright. Lots of chat going on there. So
that's awesome. Remember to help out our wonderful
teams. They're
not gonna see the obvious typos and other
mistakes because this
well, they've got a camera in their face
and that's just the way things work. So
feel free to drop that into the chat
and give them as much help and support
as you can.
We are gonna pop over to my screen
share. Now the first thing I need to
do is give you access to the other
cluster.
So this is Chen guard east.
I'm gonna change your permissions.
Ta da.
It's easy as that. Alright. You should know
all on the server page, all the machines.
I am gonna open a connection onto Chinguard
West Control Plane 1.
Please feel free
to join the session and type echo or
anything else to let me know that you're
in the session. Remember to use activity active
sessions and best of luck.
Alright. We've got one already. Awesome.
Yeah.
Gonna work someone.
Adrian living up to these excuses already. Last
one in the session. Alright.
I would encourage you to export your cube
configs, set any aliases that you want and
check for a control plane. Best of luck.
Jeez.
That's flying. See, I'm glad I'm not doing
this.
Well, you have exported kubectl
instead of kubectl. Yep.
It begins.
Capitalist.
Oh, plenty of. Thank
you, Thomas. I have no data. I know.
Thomas.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
Should we try should we try deleting those
first?
West side, the best side.
Don't know. That can be a real control
plan. Right? That could be a real API
server.
Yeah. It could be real.
Let's
just for fun, let's go look at the
actual
one.
See if they've changed anything here.
That looks like is it 8021?
Is that the right one?
Believe so. Yep.
I think you need yeah. Let's let's go
with it until Trevor knew otherwise. Changing IP
address would be particularly mean, but feel free
to run IP adder if you really wanna
check.
Nope.
I think we're good.
Wait. You guys wanna just go ahead and
try to delete this?
Let's see if there's any statements.
Take a look. What's the Everything says running.
So maybe it's all working. They've not broken
anything.
Yeah.
What is it? 3030000.
Let's just see if it's
v one's running properly.
What's the that is as a as a
zero extra zero.
Extra zero? No. 30,000. Right? Yep. 30,000 is
correct.
Oh. Do you have to do HTTPS,
or are they just playing around there?
Okay.
It is not running with TLS. It's I
can give you that. It's not running it's
not running with TLS.
They have a separate controller for Postgres.
Okay.
I mean, I can try and open the
app right away if you if you want
to try and see it.
Yeah. Cool.
Just wanna see
GCR Rawkode d one. Okay. That
looks right.
Oh, I should have written down, like, the
digest of the image, actually.
Yeah. That's fine.
That's gonna be a
thing to change the image, isn't it?
Yeah.
That doesn't look right, though. Six four four
three.
Doesn't it? Oh, they're clustered. Yes. Okay. Yep.
But you do servers. Dash run on port
eighty eighty.
Yeah.
But that's, like, con this I'm sure that's
Kubernetes
session 6443, isn't it?
The API server does. Yes.
Was I looking at the wrong one? Clustered.
Yeah.
That endpoint doesn't seem right.
Nope.
Yeah.
Are we just gonna leave till well, yeah,
that's one thing at a time. I was
gonna say we're leave those pods. They're probably
doing nothing. They're probably just decoration all those
pods.
Well They're gonna be a painfully.
Yeah. Let's go see
who this guy is.
What did you do? Get pods.
Dasha.0y.
Looking at the IP address, trying to figure
out who that endpoint is.
Could
be VIP.
Yeah. What's that?
So that is the control plane private I
p v four.
Okay. Uh-huh.
Why is your service pointing to that?
Yeah.
Wonder if we just go ahead and reexpose
reexpose
it.
Okay. Yeah. Can we just I mean, you
can probably describe the service and I don't
know that gives you.
Oh, yeah. The edit looked right.
Yes. So endpoints is just wrong. Yeah. So
just update the endpoint.
Type node port.
What is the what's the labels on pods?
Yeah. Describe. Yeah.
When I keep typing, like, clustered in Kubernetes,
I'm gonna keep getting that wrong.
Default app is clustered, k l u s
d e r d. Yeah.
So what's the selector on that service?
Clustered.
Selector. Oh, it doesn't have a selector.
Okay.
Told you they were gonna start with the
networking.
But you can't change a selector on it,
can you, after you've created it?
Because this looks right. You you can add
the selector. You can add the selector. Yeah.
Change.
Session finding. Where is the selector in the
spec?
Well, after spec, you would just have to
do selector and then Yeah. Match labels. I'm
not touching the keyboard to put the but
Carlos, just just
give Carlos a keyboard.
Yeah. I don't I don't like I don't
like to use VM as well.
Let's quit some.
It's all fine. VMAX is not installed on
these servers.
Oh, that's even worse.
So your hypothesis here is that they removed
the selector and added a manual endpoint for
the service. Is that what you're thinking?
Yes.
What is the select what's the selector on
it again, guys? I don't know. It's a
app App clustered. App app app clustered.
It's a good first guess, I would say.
You'll need to fix that end in patient.
Yeah.
I'm actually surprised that it accepted that. It
did. There you It did.
Okay.
Thomas, it's true. We shouldn't have left any
editors installed.
Was Well, that's
a good point.
Open Vim and type colon old files.
That should be fine. Right?
I'm just checking to make sure they're not
messing with those binary output. It can mess
up your terminal.
I just put it to a file you
want.
One sec.
Checks
checking
that. Okay. They they didn't mess it up
there.
We're not do we still have this old
endpoint?
No? Nope. Didn't change the endpoint.
Just make sure it's going to the right
one.
I don't need dash. Just need the clustered
port.
But one thing you could do I'm sorry.
Okay. So it is it's pointing to the
right pod.
Right. So go into the pod and crawl
from the pod and see if you get
the same thing.
Good point.
I tried to load it, and it doesn't
work.
Oh, need dash dash.
Sorry. Uh-oh.
Yeah.
I can't.
Oh, no. I'm oh, I just yelled at.
This is on 8080 in here.
Yeah.
Act just blow me the terminal. We can
always sign a new one.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's looking like
To change the what's wrong? Do a PSEUX
for it. Is
NGINX running? That.
So that's that's what you were using it
in genetics, weren't you?
Or were you using Apache,
David?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. David,
is is it running Apache inside your image?
It is not.
Yeah. It is not. Okay.
So
Like, it just faked it. This is not
David's image, I believe.
No. No. It is not.
Let's go ahead and go look at the
deployments.
Matt says he can have it. I don't
know why
my browser isn't letting me have it.
Okay. Let's have this.
That's quite does that look does that spelling
look great? I could I could imagine them
putting something up in GitHub.
Rawkode Academy,
k l s u t e r d
b one.
Okay.
I would
next thing I would do is get the
digest so we can see when that changes.
Yeah. I'm checking more clearly here with this
image.
Yeah.
And he could have done what I did
in the previous thing, which was to play
with the
container d config
dot toml.
Where is that located? Is
it it's a container d
I thought it's container d. Let me check.
What's that? It's a containerdconfig.com,
but possibly I I
don't maybe that doesn't exist unless you've,
like, made a change to it. So that
means you made no change. What's your head
what's your head cough to this right now?
What what are we worried about? What what
symptom do we have and what are you
trying to fix?
Well, I see that's the right image.
Yeah. It's not the right image.
Yeah. I just grabbed the the digest
from
the Rawkode Academy cluster d v one.
Yeah.
And it starts with F0D9.
Okay. Give me one sec.
Get pod
get pods.
Let's
just do YAML,
and I'll be lazy and just grunt for
image.
What what was it? Yeah. That's correct.
That's right? Oh.
E b yeah. That's correct.
What happens if we just kill
well, what happens if we just pull
a new version of the I mean,
So you're you're
looking at the container deconfig because you think
they've somehow
configured container d to pull something out?
That's what I did remember. So I wonder
if they're trying get revenge.
But it's possible they just uploaded a new
image onto the the nodes. With a feature?
Yeah. Yeah.
Or edited the running one.
Did we check this crazy part with the
stuff
to see what's inside those?
No. We haven't. So we can go ahead
and just look at one,
see what they're actually doing.
Thomas does suggest that you can cat minus
v for that bainery stream if you want.
Just running the box and busy box.
I'll sleep
forever.
Yeah.
It's just a
misdirection.
Oh. Do we
Let's go to the root. Let's check that
read me stuff.
Yeah. Let's try to know no spoilers here.
Right? No
spoilers here.
Let's
yeah. Okay.
This four. Mean, how much have I done?
Well, that's that's not ominous at all.
Nice.
The list of most places unexpected.
Can
we
So I'm wiping out the clustered image and
just
Yeah. I think I'm gonna So
where is this pod scheduled? And then maybe
just manually remove the image and force it
to
pull again. Yeah. That sounds
Because I'm curious and I don't know the
answer to this. Right? But the image pull
policy was always. But if it reaches out
the container registry and the digest is the
same, I'm assuming it doesn't pull the same
image.
Yeah. So you might can you get in
like So if they were if they were
able to fake the digest and being a
security
company,
I'm assuming that is where we send people
skill set,
then
that would be an interesting break.
Well, I guess you can just go into
you used to be able to just go
into, like, the file system.
But do it you can use CTR as
well.
You're in the 12
I mean, it's the 12. The ACLs, but
otherwise, it wouldn't pull. So
where's the pod schedule? So let's go delete
an image.
I gotta get that. Sorry. The wrong one.
Clustered.
Well, this well, this got their full partner.
Oh, that's right. Yeah.
Need the full one. It's not a deployment.
Being lazy.
Not YAML.
Typing
okay.
That still looks right, and it's probably still
wrong.
So do I get pods or wait and
see where it's scheduled?
Yeah.
Okay.
The previous one was in the worker.
Alright. So I suggest we jump on to
worker one.
Okay. Yeah. You're start another session for us?
I am indeed. So West
worker one.
Oh, it got a nice MOTD as I
logged in. No.
Of course, it does.
Lovely.
Alright.
I might wanna do a PS first.
Yeah.
Well, at least, like, you're not in a
container.
There seems to be a lot of fun
going on here.
Container d.
Okay.
So are you just going to try and
inject this image with cry control or CTR?
Yeah. Let's
Oh, I don't know what Craig can tell
you. Got the money. Not pleased with.
Just kill every one of them with honks.
Why we have, like,
there is some invoice here in the Busy
ambassador?
I think I wanna check and see I
just wanna check and see if there's anything
in here.
No. It doesn't look like there's anything in
there.
Yeah. CRI, CTLs, they just stop like I
would expect.
There's CTR as well. You can use dash
dash runtime dash endpoint and point it to
the computer, the socket to
cut out all those error messages.
Runtime dash To the container? Point.
Dash endpoint.
Yeah. Equals ties.
Slash run slash container d slash container d
dot stock, I believe.
This guy?
Yeah.
Although you might need it before the stock
ID thing.
Yeah.
Okay. You can tell I use this one
a lot.
Just try p s dot yeah. Or that.
You're missing an x. Okay. X.
I think you're missing the
at the end of SOC.
S o c k, right then?
Oh, maybe it's my I'm just watching on
the the videos, I guess.
Do you mind if I type for a
second?
Sure.
Run.
Enter the
yeah. There it is.
Oh.
The CTR as well. It's not not easier.
There you go.
She's done.
You should you should be able to list
images as well.
Yeah.
It's been up, but it's also restarted.
Thanks, Thomas, for the reminder.
Yes. Let's delete those images. Yep. So if
we run
KaiControl images, we can see what's on the
host.
Okay.
Probably don't need NGINX or BusyBox.
What was well, I would focus on clustered.
We've got twenty minutes left. Yep. Yeah. Exactly.
Wow.
Time time flies when you're in the hot
seat.
Does it just delete?
Or is it d Dell?
RMI
is the command that you want to delete
RMI. And then the image ID.
Just as I thought, being in the hot
seat is much different than just watching.
I think your RMA use a space after
the socket.
This is deleted.
Yeah. I deleted it. Doesn't yeah. It doesn't
exist. It's not there.
Let's
should we try to re should should we
try to delete the one that's provisioned on
the control plan and restart it? And I'm
back onto the control plan.
Oh, I'm hoping it just restart.
Yeah. Looks like it did.
I would just restart. Yeah. Yeah.
It's creating. It's creating.
Okay. It's running. Do we wanna try to
curl inside the pod again and see if
it's the right one this time? You should
be able to curl localhost 30,000.
Yeah. That's right. There.
Baylor.
I didn't expect that.
I yeah.
I didn't either.
But the image
yeah.
Should we look at it anymore of the
hints?
Apparently,
there is a hint for this issue. So
Did did we actually check the config the
container of the TOML on that the worker
node or just on the No. We did
not
check it. Okay. So that's gonna be in
cat etcd
or etcd.
Container d.
Tomo.
Nothing
nefarious in there
on the one side. Can we come up?
So I can tell you that container d
doesn't ship with a config by default. So
this was Exactly. Put there by them. And
that snapshot to me seems suspicious.
You know, I would delete the file.
Okay.
Alright. Yeah. I'll run with it. We ought
to restart something.
What we could look. What would yeah. I'm
not sure what you're a start. Yeah. You
would restart container d and then delete the
pod.
They're
rumbled. We
have all nose and crying cat faces or
shot cat faces.
Yeah. That just means it's like onto like
Yeah. We've been to the next one. Yeah.
Yeah. This is actually we stumbled into the
The first this is the first line. Yeah.
Yeah.
Thomas is saying, deleting random files from slash
e t c to fix production issues. What
could go wrong?
We're not deleting random files. We're resetting them
to the default.
Alright. I would suggest that
container d doesn't seem to be restarting, which
is not Yeah. It doesn't seem to that's
not okay.
You may wanna look at that unit file.
Yeah. I would say, like, maybe we can
get the default config
TOML and put that back.
You can container deal, put the default TOML
if you want.
But you could just edit the unit file.
Assume it I'm assuming they must have modified
something
to look explicitly for a config.
Yeah.
Carlos, do you know that? I I don't
know that.
What?
I was waiting How help is that? So
system d system.
It's gonna be okay. Where
is it? Alright. Well, let's try system control
cat container d.
I didn't know that.
Yeah. You I don't see
Well, it's just about snapshot in there that
didn't make a look of.
Oh, I think that was above my last
prompt.
Okay.
I don't see it It looks clean. Looking
for a config. Yeah. It does it looks
like it's not looking for a config file.
Does it did you control c the restart,
or did it just finish? Like, is container
d now running? I did I did a
control c. I mean, we can do
We'll do a system c l c t
l status and see what comes up. Let's
test data. Yeah.
It's just the whole thing. I would do
everything. No. Come on.
Okay. It's running.
So you might have said it took a
long time because
there are quite a lot of pods
and containers. Yeah.
Okay. So you might be alright. Let's let's
go back to control then. Let's play that
pod. Yeah.
Okay. You just have fifteen minutes left.
Well, that's Okay. You definitely But you are
doing great. Really, really good.
I don't like that post SQL controller zero.
So even if we get it get clustered
running,
something some something's going on with the database.
I can She's gonna ask me what databases
alright. We have a clustered pod.
Hey.
Hey. Hey. There we go.
Alright. Elements by tags. This this is v
one.
You make This looks right.
That's pro that's gotta be the database.
So
nicely done. I thought we made progress, but,
apparently,
maybe not. Alright.
What next?
I'm gonna delete that controller pod, but I
didn't see if there was a staple set
for it. There is.
I'm gonna remove that guy.
Is there
So what How is it
I think you were gonna go with the
same thing. How does how does cluster d
know to talk to it? It's hard coded
as a service endpoint called Postgres.
Uh-huh.
Take a look on the services.
Postgres.
And that's 10108.
Well,
let's let's go see.
Well, it came back up.
That's fun. Well, it But that has a
stateful set name,
and you deleted a pod.
Well,
I deleted the stateful set. Alright. Thought I
did. Oh,
then that's different.
I did delete it. Okay.
Maybe maybe this is in a manifest, like,
hardcore manifest in there. Let's see. That's what
I'm gonna yeah. Let's If it was a
manifest, we would see the control plane
node name as part of the
Ah. Part. Okay. I'm I'm getting serious now.
Install now you are. Sorry about the sudden
Adrian is showing up. There we go.
Do app install rip grip, and then change
directly slash Etsy rip grip honk.
You think we left some honks in the
script? You
have to change the Is it slash that
way? No. You you gotta change the directory
you want to start in.
Is Etsy. Yeah. Honk.
Yeah. I see. Sorry.
Okay.
My plan failed.
The other thing you can do is look
in Vim and put call in old files.
Matt is also saying check the hints. And
Thomas is saying that whatever situation we're in
is my fault. So sorry.
I'm not sure what I did.
We already fixed that, I believe.
I hope so. Yep. That's fixed. Yeah. Yeah.
This is fixed.
Sail. Where are we setting sail for? For
land.
Be
on the realms of control plane. Go beyond
the IP address. The IPCs of the land
and the workers were more fun awaits.
I don't think we've encountered that yet. Well,
we did go on to work and change
the the config. So we might have got
part of it, but it might be more
there. I don't know.
Mhmm.
Okay.
And then I think we already did the
CTR.
Okay. So maybe there's something still broken on
that. Oh, there you go. It doesn't have
to know. The controller the controller controls more
than you think.
We've not done that. So, like, look at
the controller,
like, Etsy manifest thing.
Yeah.
If you look under there Apparently, the worker
part is completed.
Okay. We have a node.
Yeah.
So the controller one is a Postgres hint
according to Thomas.
Oh, okay. Is a Postgres hint. I don't
know this bit.
Yeah. So you go Let's talk about what's
happening. You delete the stateful set and it
came back. How are they doing that? Yeah.
Right? There's a few ways to do that.
So let's try and work through them.
The logged in to the thing.
They're logged in to let's I want
could be a service that's wouldn't be. Yeah.
That wouldn't be very nice,
sporting.
I wonder if there's anything we already looked
in the manifest. There's no manifest in the
worker node. Wonder if there's just a there's
gotta be a script or something that's starting
the pods back up.
Could be.
A cron maybe? Yeah. Something you create the
stateful set when you called it. Right?
And he's talking.
Let's go with three.
It doesn't look like it is. That is
not Does Kubernetes have Chrome?
Yeah.
Gotta love jobs. Chrome jobs. Oh, yeah. Dash
figure. Yeah.
Not jobs. They're chrome jobs. Yep. Chrome jobs
too.
Is it just chrome jobs?
No.
May No? And what if if you want
those
bots,
that crazy pods? Like, it's not a busy
box and doing stuff,
actually. Yeah. One of them might be doing
something, you think? Yeah.
Yeah. I could do.
One of these, like Check the image names.
Yeah.
Grip. On all of on on all of
them?
Well, no. Can we not just, like, get
all the?
Get pods. Yeah.
So you can run
Get pods and then get all of them
and then just grip for the image name,
I guess. Yeah. You can run cube control
cluster info and grip that for all the
images across the entire cluster.
Say that again. Sorry. Cluster dash info.
Oh, yeah.
And just grab images?
Maybe image.
And maybe cluster info dump. I can't really
remember the exact one. Yeah.
It's probably dump. Yeah. It's got that's the
one that's got all of the information. That's
the one.
Busy bugs. Busy bugs. And Thomas is saying,
it's a worker process, and it's still my
fault.
Okay. Let's go back to the worker then.
Oh, jeez.
Let's just call it let right. Put the
control plane schedulable and call in the damn
worker. Yeah.
It doesn't matter how you fix it. Right?
Good day to you, Adrian.
Yeah. Okay.
Not pods, nodes.
Am I spelling right? Quite far off.
That's like a chef.
Cardone. Yeah. Oh. Oh. Oh.
Cartoon would be to make it religious, I
think.
And then we probably wanna kill wanna kill
cluster kill all the bugs. The rubber cable
is asking, wouldn't cardinal worker be a problem
because it's the only one?
Yeah. We need to, like, make the master
schedulable.
Yes. We can remove the tent from the
control plane.
Which is yeah. That's weird sent to We
wanna edit the way Oh, there's a good
hint from Thomas. I should be assistant to
the worker. Clearly, I've started some horrible process.
But we've cordoned it anyway. Right? So it
doesn't matter. Yeah.
SSHD
isn't.
Isn't SSHD.
We go through Teleport. We don't go through
SSHD.
Oh, jeez.
What have you stunted my cluster? My poor
little cluster.
It better not be just logged in and
doing things. That's gonna annoy me.
No. I don't think so. I I'm assuming
SSHD is a custom binary for that. Yeah.
Okay.
So I killed that.
Alright. We've got So try calling
seven minutes.
Do you want to remove a tint of
a somewhat schedulable? It's like kubectl
tint Edit. It would all help us. Well,
you called in the node, but you also
didn't drain the worker.
Although, I can't remember if a cordon does
a drain, but I still see I can't
remember. No. No. The the drain does a
cordon.
The drain does a cordon. Yes. So let's
drain that node. Which is it gonna drain?
Okay.
Drain.
What's the node's name?
Uh-oh. Do, like, you know, our dev sets
and dash dash delete dash dash
data. Yep. That's the one. You wanna type
you wanna type the One second. One second.
I was looking.
Dash dash ignore daemon sets.
Oh, what's this weird stuff?
Well, did we do the drain? I don't
think we did the drain.
I don't think it did either.
No. That is on the
cannot delete parts that not managed by replication
control or replica set. The most set or
stateful set.
Five minutes.
East I think we still need to make
the control plane schedule, though. Right? Indeed.
Yeah. Somebody wanna get the syntax from that.
Yeah. It's gonna be like kubectl
taint nodes,
the control plane node, and then You can
just edit the nodes and remove the taint.
Oh, cool. Yeah. Let let's let's make this
quick. We've got four and a half minutes.
Cool. Kubectl edit. Yeah.
Oh, let me get the name.
God. That time
is of the essence.
Alright. So such a tense. That's the one.
Bye bye bye.
Alright. You now have
a note that we'll schedule.
Okay.
We ought to restart anything for that. The
pods should be scheduled there now.
Yep. There you go.
Okay. And the
I've got the fun ones still coming up.
To remove a little frustration, SSH is working
on and kill all of Rawkode's processes.
Well, we we've removed that note from the
equation.
I'm hoping Yeah.
Hoping.
I wanna get rid of the staple set
too.
Are you? I bet it's gonna come back
up. Is it? No?
No. No?
Okay.
So you have the v one image at
least.
So let's get it upgraded. Oh,
the image the image is there?
Yes. So edit it and change it to
v two and see what happens.
Okay.
Edit.
Employed spelling
spelling
clustered.
I think yeah.
Oh, next one.
Where'd it go?
No.
Well, I oh, I'm not looking at the
stream.
We got the image with the hair again.
Again.
So we we need to kill those processes.
Okay.
But that's interesting. Is it
I mean, that's running on this pod, which
presumably doesn't have the
and you got pull always. Right?
I just killed the the session for it.
Alright. I have logged off of that bot
killing the two processes that appeared to be
under my user ID.
You might have to delete that image on
on this part again,
on the control plane, like, the CR,
price detail, whatever you want to use.
Is it images?
Let it yell at us.
You're talking about the
post presser.
Oh, v two clustered.
That's what I'm thinking.
Okay.
Deleted. And then
I've removed or removing all their crap from
the bash RC.
Does that code command work?
Nope. Still getting it here.
Sorry? Well, we still have those road processes
again, but I I need to remove Yeah.
Okay. I have removed it.
What?
You said that control. I thought we got
rid of that. Yeah. But I think Yeah.
Me logging into this machine keeps bringing it
back.
What?
This is gonna have to be explained.
Yeah.
So there's a process on that thing that
SSH is into the control plane.
Yeah.
That's gonna be good.
Where are we in a minute? What's what's
currently wrong?
It's still directing to the wrong database.
Okay.
We didn't look at some of the other
license. We've only got
less than a minute, anyhow.
Time is up.
Alright. Thomas, do you wanna jump on and
walk us through how to fix this before
we switch teams?
Come on.
Looks like very active in the chat and
you seem to know what's going on here.
But apparently, there's an SSHD process.
Which is running at Rawkode, not Rawkode.
I killed it on the I thought I
killed it on the worker, not on the
control plane.
Alright. So I've killed it again. So if
we bounce the postgres pod, we should be
working again?
Oh, I I closed out of my session.
Somebody's still in.
Oh, do do you need to come out?
I'm doing.
He said it's it is running as Rawkode.
It didn't look like it to me.
You probably wanna kill that postgres controller zero
stateful set as well.
That seems to be doing some bad things.
Thomas
says it's running as Rawkode.
I'll look at it quickly. I mean, I
don't see it.
Alright. Here he is.
Yeah.
Oops.
Hello.
You hold off the page?
Hi, Thomas. Did you get it did you
get it fixed here?
You did. We did.
So
what was going on with that? SSHD
Postgres controller?
So the the Postgres controller was overriding
adding a SQL injection attack
to Yeah.
But
on the worker, there was a a
program purporting to be SSHD
running as Rawkode that would keep reapplying the
manifests when you for people who thought to
delete the stateful set. So I'm sorry.
No. No. It we were so close. But
No. It was good. You got it. Yeah.
Well done. Yes. But there was a lot
to a lot to fix there.
Very well done indeed.
Alright. Lairs. I'm
gonna invite on Tengard West and say goodbye
to Tengard East. Thank you for joining us.
I really was on. That was great. And
then I'll speak to in second. Just
remember, tomorrow is the April fool's day.
Yeah.
We tried violence everywhere. Alright.
Let's see. Where is West?
Is it fun watching someone try and fix
your cluster, Thomas?
That was a doozy. I'm I'm actually really
impressed with how much progress they made. I
could not have made
that much progress in forty five minutes. That
was incredible.
Someone still has the stream open. Might be
a good time to mute or close that.
Alright.
So Can you hear me? Yeah. We can.
Welcome.
Yeah. We can. Awesome. Someone has a stream
open,
can you find the tab and close it,
please? I have it.
Is someone still watching?
Someone's still watching.
I'm I'm not.
Alright. I can mute these one by one,
and we'll work out who it is. Alright.
I could do. I
believe it's Matt.
Matt. Maybe my AirPods.
Hello?
Is that better?
It is. Is that better? We're good. I
don't hear myself. It is. Oh, no. I
still hear myself. I hear myself. Okay. I'm
still gonna keep talking. I've muted everyone else
but Matt.
I don't hear myself. Alright. Let's swap around.
Alright.
Is
you. Do you have the stream open?
I've never said that handle out loud before.
I don't know if I said it right
either.
Audio is breaking down at what was that?
You have the YouTube video open, I think,
somewhere.
Like You have video sync somewhere.
Right?
The YouTube video? Nope.
I have the the chat, but that's it.
Okay.
I I can't hear myself right now. Oh,
no. I can't.
Yeah. It's definitely coming from you. So that
you have a tab somewhere with the stream
open.
I found it and in mute. Awesome. Thank
you. Alright. Let's get this underway. So you
guys are all a very, very mean team,
but that was a great fun to watch.
So
let's start with some introductions and then we'll
see what team have in store from you.
So let's start with Thomas, work our way
around clockwise, and we'll get this underway.
Hey, folks. My name is Thomas Stromberg.
I am
a software engineer at Changuard,
but, I've done, some other,
random things in the past, including being a
a minikube,
maintainer, which helps me understand some of the
underlying issues here and know some of the
bad things to introduce into a system since
people seem to keep introducing it into mine.
So
but nonetheless,
yeah, I'm glad to be here, and it
was awesome to see the
how
Team East fixed our cluster.
That was just absolutely incredible job, folks. So
Awesome. Thank you.
Who wants to go next?
Don't be shy.
You're both muted.
Again. There we go.
So is that all gone? Maybe.
Yeah. My name is,
and I am also a super engineer at.
And I
also
work in Kubernetes
as a in secret list mainly.
And
I'm
kind of scared of to see what our
friends have led for us.
Awesome. Thank you. Matt?
Hey. Can you hear me? Yeah. We can.
I did. Okay. Yeah. The the
there was a mute
icon over my picture even though I was
unmuted. So
hi. I'm Matt. I'm one of the founders
of ChainGuard,
and I am incredibly nervous.
That was a lot of fun, and and
congratulations
to team East.
That was very
well done.
Yeah. They did they did great. They were
so close. I think we should just give
it to them as a fix. Like Oh,
yeah. Totally. I think I was hinder on
them more at the end than they were
themselves.
So let's get my screen share up.
Here we go.
I am going to open a session on
ChainGuard
East
control blame one this time.
Once this opens, please use activity active sessions
to join.
Type echo or anything so that I know
you are there, and then we will get
this underway.
So let's see who we have in our
cluster.
I got access denied.
Oh, I haven't given you access yet. Oh,
there you go. That's a a problem right
off the bat. So
apologies.
Here we go.
I wonder if this were our friends.
You have access now. You can join my
session.
Promise. There we go. We got our first
echo. Alright. Matt's in.
Echo.
Enjoy, Thomas.
I can't hear him. It looks like he's
talking now.
Thomas, you're on mute.
Oh, is he frozen?
There he is.
Hello?
No. I think he has frozen. So until
Thomas oh, he's in at least. So that's
good.
Alright. Set up your cube config.
Check for a control plane and best of
luck. I'll reset your timer now. Just so
you got a bit more time.
Alright.
So let's see. For the first thing, I
think we should check
that history.
Empty. Covered their tracks. Nice try. Nice try.
Let's see.
So
let's see. So the next bit
of advice
was to dump some useful events
with SleuthKit.
Welcome back, Tom.
SDC
three.
Okay.
You want this
with
dev
s e c three.
And SwiftKit returns.
Not the first time Thomas brought this on
many episodes ago.
Let's see. Alright. So Some of the work
we did was try to hide that.
So for the anyone in the audience that's
not familiar with SwiftKit, who wants to go
to the TLDR about what FLS is doing?
I mean I mean, Tom, it's good.
Yeah. Basically,
yeah, it's it's generating
a file system timeline is is what this
is doing of
all the most recent changes to the the
control plane.
It may not be as useful since people
know about this trick, but it definitely was
effective the first time I presented it.
So, yeah, Sleuth Kit, old school
forensics tool.
Right. Even shows deleted files.
Did it recover the batch history?
I'm afraid not easily, but kind of.
There we go.
I don't see
I mean, this a lot of this stuff
just looks like system libraries
probably
pulled in through
the app get install.
So I'm assuming SwiftKit is handy if there's
rogue things still on the file system. But
if people broke the cluster explicitly
through a cube control, it's probably not as
useful. Right? Because there's only entity that's really
gonna change.
So let's see if we can
alright.
No control plan. Maybe see what it looks
like.
Yeah. Let's
see. Is it still on my clipboard?
No.
Let me grab the
app.
Oops.
If we check this out
does this look right?
I guess we can
I don't know? Is it
should it be going or let's see. I
mean, I can only see the key data.
I I can't see anything.
I have to to debug right now.
Oh,
I can resize the window.
Is that more readable?
It is. Yep.
At the very top
There we go.
Yeah. At the very top,
it's basically
an IP
443,
and I assume that's right, but, I guess,
we should take a look at the running
containers.
Let's see.
So
we need an API server running.
So I guess we should take a look
at
the
container d stuff to see what containers we
have.
So let's
so
you see a control point. We so we're
on the control point node. I don't I
see the API server here,
right,
in the middle.
So
should we check out the logs on that?
Let's see.
Think you're overlooking something subtle. The right one.
Right? Oh, it should
be 6443.
There we go.
On the cube config. I didn't wanna tell
you. I didn't wanna just burst out with
that since you were so cruel to the
the other team.
Let's
see.
You
got it all.
Alright. So looks like that
may have restored some stuff.
But
it looks like some pods are failing to
schedule. So I'm guessing our node is a
wall. It may have the same problem on
the node.
Let's see. Cute cuddle. Get nodes.
Bro. But, you know, they're not ready, including
the control plans. So if we let's see.
Get pods
Pending.
Yeah.
Okay. So we've got one terminating one
let's
see.
Someone talking. I I hear something very faint.
It may just be an echo, though.
Yeah. I think there's still a
YouTube tab somewhere
in the background. Alright.
We're gonna check for old tricks.
Alright.
No webhooks registered.
So
let's describe the nodes, I guess.
I'm assuming this is is all James. What
what does it mean when a control when
a node is not ready?
Well, it should show up in describing the
notes. Right? On schedule.
Schedule.
Let's see. That's,
I think, normal
for the master.
Right?
Let's see.
Where's
the where's the resource settings?
So allocatable,
there's a lot of CPU
and a lot of memory.
K.
Ready.
Oh, it says let's see. Complete posting ready
since said former enabled.
Not ready. True.
Reason Kubelet ready. So not ready. True. Kubelet
ready. This I don't know. Maybe that's normal,
but that looks strange.
Let's see.
And then the other node is ready,
unknown.
Node status unknown. Kubelet stopped posting node status.
So there's something clearly broken broken with the
with the
worker.
Let's
describe them one at a time.
Should we try and get the control plane
working first?
Have
you checked the application yet?
It's not the pods aren't scheduling.
K.
Right.
Think it'll get pods. Right? So, I mean,
the pods are a mix of terminating and
pending.
Right?
I mean, we can take a look at
the application,
which is running on a node port here
with its IP adder.
Space adder.
Sorry? IP space adder.
Oh,
where are we looking? That's a modified piece.
So when you described the notes, something's stood
out to me.
A lot of the checks,
the timestamps were quite old.
Sorry. When we what? When you described the
notes.
We described the nodes. Yeah. And when you
were looking at the status check,
like, these timestamps are quite old.
These timestamps.
Well, the last transition time.
The network one specifically.
You're the last heartbeat?
The last heartbeat. Yeah.
Yeah. So let's
let me take a look at
so Cilium is running,
but
Yeah. So when it's running, but it was
updated two days ago.
I guess we can take a look at
those.
Now that we have the control plane back,
we should take a look at the images
we are running.
So let's
take a look at these.
Let's see. So we've got
emissary.
We've got Kuvip. We've got a bunch of
Kubernetes
images.
And then we've got the Quay
Cilium
images,
which is Cilium
and operator generic.
Those look like the right versions and the
right hashes.
So it doesn't look like they
tampered with the actual
specs.
Let's see.
Maybe check the
how long how the some of those have
been running to see if
we can maybe get an idea if they
were redeployed.
I mean, they've been running for
two days, two hours, it looks like, but
it says
so I guess we can
Cillium's probably running as a human set here.
Come here and get
that.
So
let's see. So the actual thing itself is
two days, two hours, and that's how old
the pods are.
They may have messed with the pods.
Mean, we could try bouncing the pods.
Let's see.
See.
Pod
session.
What's it? Cilium system.
That
namespace.
No.
They are static pods.
Or they're running somewhere else. Let's see. At
pods.
So they are running cube system.
Oh, that's fine. Okay. So let's see.
Next part. We can describe this part.
No events on our project volume. Let's see.
But, yeah, the the
config map, I wonder, for for Cilium.
I wonder if anything has changed there. I
saw because I saw that Cilium did restart.
So where are they mounting it from?
I mean, it's gotta be m cube system.
Mounts.
M
Solium. Figment.
Let's
volume.
So
that's the mount.
Let's see. We sync map names. These
which are post pads.
Third
API access.
So there should be config map.
Map. Yes.
Here we go. So it's only in config.
Alright.
So I got
see, I'm
three.
That doesn't mean anything.
Okay.
So
let's see.
I have no idea what this is supposed
to look like.
Let's see. So we missed you proxy
since is some sort of mesh setting.
Node port bind protection through monitor aggregation.
I guess
it should be in the clustered repo. Right?
So we should be able to compare with
what it should be.
Right?
Slim endpoint,
secrets feed two,
Port ranges. C b o.
Nothing
is jumping out at me. This feels like
the standard Cilium config that I deploy with
Helm.
It
Doesn't mean I've not missed anything, but it
looks alright.
Yeah. So, I mean, we could try bouncing
the pods.
What do you think?
I would encourage it. I'm curious to see
if it works. I reckon
at one,
I think.
Let's see. Let's not delete
everything. Let's delete.
May maybe just bounce the clustered pod and
see the the error messages and
Because the fact that we have a clustered
pod and a terminate and pending status. I
think we have a I think there's a
issue with the kubelet on that node.
Alright. So kubel pods.
So
we wanna try, like, deleting the the terminating
one?
Do cuddle. Delete.
Pod.
I mean, it's
it's hanging.
Yeah. I think what's happening is the API
server is trying to delete that, but the
kubel is unresponsive on the worker node.
Right. And it's not been able to update
the statuses of things.
You might wanna
I I I don't know. I mean, I
give the worst replaced ever, but you might
wanna jump onto the worker node.
Let me open up the session. Yeah.
I wanna look at the logs from the
API server now that we can.
Yep.
And
I would be curious on the worker node
to
check for any
modifications to Etsy
for, like, CNI files or cubelet files.
There you go.
Unable to authenticate.
Invalid bear token. So I'm guessing they fuzz
with the off of Google it on the
worker.
There's a session open. Feel free to join
the worker node. Alright.
And
you have twenty four minutes.
Alright. No pressure. See. Session in progress.
This
is let me make sure I'm connected to
the right one. Alright.
Join session.
A question from Robert Cable, better token.
This is the API token sent to the
API server to authenticate request from other nodes
in the cluster.
Good question. Let's see. So
I'm not sure where the Kubelet pulls that
from.
Okay. Are you on the market node? The
same one as me? Yes. You are. Awesome.
Yeah. You can see me diving. Okay.
Let's see.
Take a peek at the Kubelet flags. That's
a I guess we can look at SleuthKit
here.
Let's see. So no Kubelet config.
That's exciting.
Can
we just take a look at at CCNA?
I'm just curious.
I feel like there's something with subnet somewhere,
and that would be a
curious place to look.
Is that enabled debug?
I
mean
I don't see any subnets there. So
but you'd click config maybe.
Yeah. We can look at the coupon. So
we didn't set up to config here, did
we? There is no Kubernetes access from the
working node unless they have left it somewhere.
There is a kubelet.conf
inside Etsy Kubernetes.
Oh, and a honk.
We'll get back to that. Oh, yeah. Port's
not in here.
Current .pem.
Okay.
Well, we saw off problems. Right?
I'm wondering whether there's something funny going on
here.
What's in the honk?
Yeah. Well Yeah. That seems a bit weird.
This
is that right?
This looks funny.
We'll come back to that. Let's see. So
kubla con you said honk.
Yeah. So let's
nothing.
Let's I don't believe you.
Okay.
Well, I think that directory is probably just
broken to signal that something's going on here.
So
I think that
this is clearly
our problem.
We need to replace this with
probably one of these other twos, the c
r t or the key.
Let's look at
I'm just looking on the server side what
that's set to for the config.
Maybe check the Kiplet logs?
We can do that.
Let's see.
You have twenty minutes.
Time flies when you're having fun. Right?
Yeah. So let's see. So we want
service. Here we go. So we want this.
Failed to start container for Cilium operator crash
loop back off.
So do we think it's a static pod?
No. Cilium runs as a daemon set.
Alright. Well, I'm wondering whether
so syncing pod.
Let's see.
Actually, back off, though. It's interesting. Your Chengard
friends from Team East are encouraging you to
read the certificate.
Read read the certificates.
Okay.
Let's see.
So that was in, what, PKI?
It was in FireLib Kubelet PKI.
Firelib
Kubelet
PKI.
Yeah. I haven't seen this set up before
with client current and timestamps.
I don't know specifically if this is how
the certificate rotation happens with Kubernetes. Maybe someone
can fill us in if they know.
I haven't seen it before.
Interesting.
Yeah. I think you may wanna use open
SSL here.
I'm wondering whether they
who knows open SSL.
X
five zero nine.
Just without the dash x
or and
into
the
to the file
dash text.
Minus in in minus
infile. Yeah. Dash in.
K.
Mhmm. Alright.
Then in file.
Then
dash text.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright. Issuer, ChainGuard East.
Is that just because of the cluster name,
or are they messing with us?
I'm not sure.
I'm being I
I'm having problems. Oh, there you go. Yeah.
Look at the validity.
Oh, no. Wait. They're okay. Yeah. I thought
it was 2222.
It's 2223.
Are you doing that? Yeah. Am.
I wonder if we can rejoin the cluster
with Cube ATM.
Don't know what's the Cube. Some doubts off
my head. But
The chat is saying those are expired. But
they don't look expired. Right?
No. They what's They're okay. This is the
thirty first. Not not after
after March 29. Yes. This is invalid.
Right?
Because it's the thirty first. But it's also
2023,
not after 2023.
Oh, okay. Yeah. I made that mistake too.
Yeah. Okay.
Alright. So this is around when the cluster
was set up, I think. Yeah. I think
so.
Let's see. I'm I'm looking at the same
files on the
Alright. We got sixteen
minutes.
Yeah. What about the hints? Yeah.
Are there hints?
For the hints? I think. So Carlos is
suggesting who owns the search, and James is
saying maybe look at a different search.
Okay. So I'm I'm getting the vibe that
definitely fucked with the search.
Let's see.
What are the other files? Oh, we look
at the intent in this directory.
Well, they may have covered their tracks. So
We know by now on cluster never to
trust the timestamps on a fail. Right?
Alright. So we've got this. We've got let's
see.
They at least look like certs.
We want what?
You're at East Worker 1 CA.
That
where's the validity?
Yep. 2023.
That looks.
There we go.
New bullet, get name, no start line.
Well, I don't know. That's not a sort
of a key. So
I don't know. I don't
let's see. Shall we shall we get a
hint?
Sure.
I'm I'm poking at the same files on
the
control plane. Let's see. Let's
look at the file. Says it's 2359.
Yeah. So the the size of Kubelet that
CRT is different
on the two things
and
Yeah. They're
pretty close to the same size on the
key.
I don't
but I guess the CRT file is
it's in the same open SSL.
Me
restriction.
Yeah. I I don't know how to fix
these certs. So I guess we can try
KubeADM.
So if
we let me see if my thingy
is still here. Yep. That custom data,
that's how we provision the cluster. And inside
of this is the join token.
I'll just leave that there. You can use
it if you want.
Okay.
So, yeah, there's a k d m join,
and one of the flags is, like, to
provide that token.
But I don't know if it'll reset the
certs.
Main API server endpoint. So this is
looking for A QPDM reset would probably wipe
all those certs away. Right?
The endpoint
is this. So
we want, what, API server
join API server endpoint. So that's this. Yeah.
There there's there's
also the exact command and the cloud in
a config, which I can point you out
as well if that helps. Like,
rather than working through that.
Varlib
instance.
It's just directory called script.
Living. Grip.
Join.
Yeah. Part seven.
Kube join token
discovery endpoint. Yeah. What's the name? We may
want to do the the Kube ADM reset,
though, first just to make sure that the
old
configs get blown away.
Okay.
Sorry.
Two ADM. I lost focus for a second
there.
I'm gonna copy this line just to have
it.
So reset. What flags does this state?
We flag remove its number. Yeah. I don't
think you need any any flags. I I
think you can just run it.
Any changes made.
It'll be reverted.
Yes. Okay.
Alright. Do we think that oh, do we
think that was Now we need to join
it. Yeah. Man,
yeah, I don't know if it removed the
certs, but hopefully it did. So let's try
that join again, the Cubadian join
that was in that file.
Yeah.
That's here.
The join so we need the join token.
So let's see. That was
Search for custom data.
This is yeah. That custom data. So the
join token, what's this? And the DS name
is also there.
And for free, blah blah blah. Okay. DNS
name is
East.
Let's see. Oh, I have an echo in
there.
Kubernetes
can proxy forbidden.
Cannot access config maps in
group system. There's been a value for resolve
conf in
this is interesting. Of course. Because when you
upload this
information to the config map, it only lives
for two hours.
Alright. We're just gonna have to call it
on the worker, work on the control plane,
I think.
I don't think we can recover from that
QPDM reset.
Oh, the work is ready, apparently. They would
look at that for
some time. So let's see.
Shit.
Let's let's
check our pods.
So the pods are all running now.
Should we try hitting it? You can try
the admin.
Yep.
I guess we can oops. Curl local
local host.
Action refused.
That's not surprising.
Alright.
So there's a bunch of stuff still not
running here. This app's not running.
So
the things that we're terminating seem to have
okay. And there's
there's a new replica set on the clustered
deployment. So There's a good comment in the
chat as you wanted to rejoin the worker,
but I don't think you you need to.
We could have used QEDM
token create to get a a new working
token. But I I think we can just
work with a control plan.
Let's see.
Let's take a look at the YAML for
this because there's a new
app. Rolling
updates.
Wondering what they changed. Yeah. Okay. The health
checks are on 9090.
That looks
wrong.
Let's look at the replica sets now. Yeah.
Everything runs on 8080.
Yeah.
Whoops. Let's see. There should be two replica
sets. We can look at the old one.
80 80, and then let's see.
View before,
and the other one was
this.
And then after and just see what else
they changed.
After.
Alright. So they changed the ports,
and then the rest looks real. A failure
threshold changed.
Bill or replicas for your okay. So that's
status. So
let's see. So
editor,
Nano,
kubectl,
edit, deploy.
Weird.
Well, that's fun.
I can't even control c this.
They fuck with me. What have you done?
Maybe it's still not working. Alright.
I
I've opened a new session on control plane
east.
Nano does appear to be okay.
Let's see.
Move tab to the other group.
Alright.
Well, that's fun.
I don't I it's it's Nano Breaks on
these shared XTAR JS things.
Oh,
well, okay.
I'm installing Emacs. I can't I don't speak
with them.
Eight minutes left. No. I need Emacs.
Maybe maybe a bio break. I don't know.
This is taking a while.
Shouldn't back out as next minutes to see
if it finishes installing the time.
Yeah. This is
There we let's
so let's see. Kubectl edit.
Let's try this one more time.
Oh, you need to reexport your config as
well.
Export.
Yeah. Okay. Let me grab the thing from
my cheat sheet.
KubeConfigadmin.com.
Alright.
Five
and a half minutes.
I have confidence in you.
Alright.
I have here. We've never seen an Emacs
on cluster before. That's a first, by the
way. Just Well, that's because and we when
we broke your cluster
a year ago,
whatever we did to rename v I to
emacs didn't work.
Let's see. Eighty eighty.
This should be eighty eighty.
There it is. Yeah.
It should be 80.
Does the max have search and replace?
It does. Because v I does. It's really
good.
It
does. I've been using Versus code. I'm a
little rusty.
That's
It's the shit. I mean, it's not installing
Versus Code web on these servers. I think,
actually, a lot of people would really appreciate
that.
Let's
see.
HP
local host
at
30,000.
Still a connection refused. So let's see. Let's
check that service ads. Let's see which
service
also changed to Huddl edit cluster.
That would service cluster 9090.
Okay. So we want 80808080.
I
keep I keep using
Nano.
Alright.
It did not oh,
for some reason, it's sticking garbage at the
beginning of the file. Let me save.
And here,
this garbage.
Eighty eighty. Okay. That'll be fuck up. No.
It's not okay.
Hey, also mess with this.
No.
Here we go. Failed to connect the database.
Three minutes.
Yeah. So they probably changed the ports on
that too. Yeah.
And it's there. It's maybe.
So let's see. Postgres.
What port is it supposed to run on?
Five four three two.
That's the MySQL port. Right?
It's the MySQL
MySQL port. Yeah.
Nice.
Let's see. So I'm
guessing that there's some similar changes on the
Postgres side. So that's running as a staple
set.
Postgres Uh-huh.
QL.
The service is Postgres. The they will set
as Postgres QL mostly because I hate people.
I really need to fix that. It should
be the same. So this is named 5432.
Yeah. Okay.
Port five four three two.
Is that what port is supposed to be?
It is. Yeah.
But somewhere there's a 330 6 in one
of the configs at least.
And the service was it not? No? And
there's garbage. Yeah. I think there's garbage at
the beginning of file too.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm not saving it.
So they may have just messed with the
service on this. So 5432?
Yes. Just put Postgres. Yeah. There we go.
Yeah. It's for some reason, it's inserting garbage.
Every time it's open. So
let's see. Yeah. There it Yeah.
432.
5 4 3 2.
Great. Right? Yep.
Alright. Let's
scroll.
Close to fail to connect. Let's give it
a second.
Failed to connect.
Not quite.
Let's see. You were pretty quick on the
end points changes.
Let's grasp end points. None.
Do you think by fixing the typo and
the service, you broke the Oh.
You mean, type on the service. So you
think that maybe it's
yeah. Get deploy.
You've got all. Get deployment.
Stateful set.
Well, I only changed the selector in the
deployment. Right?
Well, maybe they've done the same with this
service.
That was first one. Clustered.
Oh, yeah. So this looks right. App plus
We
can look at the same thing on
CS PostgresQL.
So PostgresQL,
and if we look at the service,
which is
Postgres.
Promise to fix that for next time. Postgres.
Oh my god.
Let's see. Postgres.
Time is up. Nice to see if we
can finish it in the next few minutes.
I I feel like we're close.
I blame
I blame Emacs.
Installing Emacs.
Let's
see.
So that,
curling it. Hey.
It's back if we edit the deployment.
V one.
Keep hitting control o.
Alright. And now we have grab it. Some
sort of
end with the control l. Alright.
So
v one
v two.
I think we may be done.
Yay. Did you curl it?
Yeah. It should v two web m. Oh,
there we go.
Perfect.
If you wanna try it, we can we
can confirm, but I
Yeah. I think you got it. Let's let's
have a look anyway. Right? So
east.
Sometimes it's
You may need HTTP.
So as
well.
Let's see.
Okay.
Oh, there we go. Sometimes it just doesn't
work, and I could role play an IP.
But you do have to dance.
But I'm really confused right now because
there is no worker node.
I I think it's there.
Think it's connected. I think
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I I think it it got
joined successfully.
But we could be the end reset it,
and the join didn't work. Right?
The join did work, but it did error
a bunch.
But it did say in the end that
it did join. Oh,
alright. Alright. Alright. Oh, good. There we go.
Phew. That was tough. Yeah. After the hours,
got
showed up in there.
Wow. Must be fun to work at chain
guards because they're all pure evil.
We use our power for good. Uh-huh. Alright.
Well, it was good of you to use
your power for evil for custard at least.
Those are two great breaks and two great
axes as well. That was a really good
fun.
It's much more fun breaking them.
Yeah.
I guess it is.
I mean, when you do show up to
FX episode with VMAX though, I mean, things
are always gonna go wrong.
I actually really like VMAX, but I I've
never got the hang of all the different
key combinations to really be effective with it.
The funny the funny control characters and my
completely
broken muscle memory from using Versus code and
nano
on my MacBook,
I think, have ruined me for Emacs, but
it's still faster than
me me trying to use VI.
So Yeah. I might actually experiment with running
the web version of Versus Code on the
server and just giving it access to the
entire disk. I think that could be funny.
Alright.
Well, thank you all for joining me. I
hope you enjoyed that.
I'll let you get back to your day.
To everyone who watched, thank you for all
your comments and the chat. It was a
pleasure watching you help out.
And it's always fun for me to try
and ponder the teams as much as possible.
I really felt guilty after that Kubeadm reset
when I don't think we'd get that back.
So I was really relieved that that worked.
And thank you to our sponsors, Equinix Medal
and Teleport. Mhmm. Custard will be back next
week. Until then, have a great day. Thank
you,
Yeah. Thank you.